Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 2nd,
2018 what's going on?
How
a,
as you can tell,
oh,
freckle cyst under the word.
Yeah.
I tried to do too much when I was on the road.
Uh,
uh,
I'm just an old guy enough and ended up catching a cold that goes to the middle
of fucking winter that's flew into Minneapolis the day of the show.
I usually,
I used to fly in the night before when I got the Kiddo and I don't know,
you know,
misses a little bit of,
her whatever day is possible.
So I flew out the day of,
then I landed and I've learned this lesson 50 fucking times and every time I've
got sick I landed.
I was a little tired,
you know,
cause I had to get up early to get there on time and I went right to the gym.
Stupid fucking move.
Then I had to do two shows and then I hung out with Verdesian fucking Barnick
but I slept in the next day and next day I woke up.
I kind of felt runned out,
but I was like,
no ma'am.
And hit the gym again.
I hit the gym again,
fucking moron.
Then I take a steam,
then I go on fucking stage,
have one show CN in the night.
I absolutely love Barnet conversion and hey,
let's go out again.
So we go out again.
And this time we were,
we were at an outside bar up on this rooftop and it's really cool,
you know,
placing,
downtown Minneapolis and a,
I had a hat on,
but it wasn't enough.
And I could tell when I was,
you know,
when a cold just get ya and I'm feeling a little bit and then it's just getting,
you're like,
ah,
fuck.
Here we go.
And I didn't have any vitamins.
That's another thing.
I forgot my vitamins,
all of that dumb shit.
So,
um,
I dunno.
So I apologize for being so frigging late here,
but however I want to thank everybody.
It's one of the most fun weekends I've had as far as crowds and just what I got
to see in Minneapolis and Detroit.
Um,
Minneapolis,
first of all,
did a theater there on,
on the,
the campus of,
uh,
the big 10 university of Minnesota.
Now,
I was joking with the people there whenever I go,
you know,
to a great campus like that.
My first thought,
this is for all you young kids out there.
I always think to myself,
man,
I wish I studied in high school.
I wish I tried.
This is fucking amazing.
That we drove by,
there was like a frat house and there was like 10 frat guys sitting in a circle
playing some drinking games outside this amazing fraternity,
you know,
and I know everybody makes fun of them saying they're a bunch of date rapists
and then this and then that and all this shit.
But at the end of the day,
who's making the robots that are going to kill all of us?
It's the nurse.
So he's up on the Frat boys.
Um,
they're not all rapists,
you know,
some of them just lear.
So anyways,
and I couldn't believe how fucking beautiful,
beautiful,
the University of Minnesota's campuses,
and I would say it on stage.
This is what you're a fucking moron.
I am.
I,
you know,
without ever seeing a campus,
I judge what it looks like by how your sports teams are doing.
If you haven't won a big 10 championship or an SCC championship in a long time,
I just figured that your school's a dump and it doesn't look good.
I'm,
I learned that with Vanderbilt.
Vanderbilt's never like,
you know,
I think maybe in baseball they're good,
but they never do anything in football and never do anything at hoops on this.
Like,
oh,
that's like almost a community college.
Then Nate board Gutsy told me it was a big fan of theirs.
It was like,
no,
dude,
that's like,
it's one of the best schools in the country.
Some of the smartest things.
It's engineering fucking eggheads school.
Right.
Um,
but I went off to University of Minnesota.
It's like all fucking brick.
I mean,
what I saw of it was a,
it was incredible.
Now I always have that thought,
like,
why didn't I study?
It wasn't that hard.
I was such a fucking pussy.
I was such a baby.
A couple of [inaudible] to subject and just,
yeah.
Did you get through it?
You know what I mean?
I didn't like doing hell runs either,
but I had to do them to get to do a fucking Gig at University of Minnesota.
I stuck with that.
Right.
Hang on.
Sorry.
I forget me.
It's going to be a lot of that.
I'll hit pause next time.
Um,
yeah,
look,
some of the math I get,
you know,
cause I gotta be honest with you.
Like I was cool right up until Algebra.
If I wasn't such a fucking class clown in a jerk off,
I wouldn't have had to go to summer school after Algebra cause it wasn't that
bad.
If I applied myself geometry,
I don't even know what,
I don't even know what the fuck was going on.
It was like these conspiracy theories about shapes,
not good spirit.
They were proven,
um,
like the NBA is fix was proven when they had that mobbed up ref.
And of course they blame it on one guy.
They always blame it on one guy.
I don't know how long people would sit there and watch the NBA.
I'm not saying all the Games of fixed,
I'm just saying no other sport is it finessed the way that sport is finesse to
make sure they had these match ups that are going to get ratings and it all goes
back to fucking Larry Bird and magic Johnson.
I'm convinced of it and it's still fucking terrified because they almost went
out of business in the late seventies.
Um,
or ratings were way down,
you know,
but they all do it like during the steroid era.
Do you think the fucking owners and baseball,
like they didn't know what the players were doing.
Baseball was in a bad way.
They canceled the world series.
Cal Ripkin breaking a Lou Gehrig's record was all the fucking head.
They choose up the ball,
they make the ballparks smaller.
These fucking guys are going up.
They looking like the dad and the Incredibles,
you know,
fucking skinny legs and giant upper bodies just drive and shit over the,
out of the frigging Ballpark,
say anti what was going on.
And then all of a sudden the shit hits the fan and not one owner got asked a
question.
They,
oh,
I had no idea.
We had no idea.
You're in the business.
Right.
I do stand up comedy.
I know who some of the up and coming funny people are.
I hear who's stealing jokes.
I hear who's going to be the next fucking whatever I hear who is maybe a fucking
party and too much.
She a year,
you're in it,
you know,
it's what you do.
Fucking lumber jacks.
They know who's a jerking off behind a redwood.
I mean,
they're in the fucking business.
So baseball was finessed that way,
I believe.
Right?
Football.
What they did was they just,
you know,
they weren't satisfied with their fan base and they just kept,
every fucking rule ended up being for the offense to the point.
It was borderline illegal to,
uh,
you know,
to fucking cover a receiver.
Now everybody's out there putting up Dan Marino numbers,
which is fucking ridiculous.
Dan Marino,
Dan Fouts,
those guys played back when you could borderline murder somebody stick them and
all of that shit.
I remember one year that year drew Brees,
I keep,
forget what he threw four,
but it was just like,
there was like seven people on pace to break down Marino's record,
maybe not seven.
It's probably four
in a in one season.
So it's finesse that fucking way.
Right?
Hockey I eat,
I don't know what they're doing.
They just,
they,
they finally got it right.
They finally got it right with Nashville and Vegas and now they're going to
Seattle.
I think they're finally going to take a turn.
And my only concern is that it's going to become immensely popular,
which is really a pipe dream.
But if it becomes immensely that,
the reason why hockey's still fucking great is because it is sort of the Jan
Brady,
the Middle Kit,
like nobody's fucking paying attention to it.
So you meet the players,
they're all cool.
They're fucking down to earth.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
Sorry.
I've even taken any cold medication.
This is just literally my intellect,
so I can't blame anything here.
Um,
but basketball,
I swear to God,
like the Celtics are common on right,
and the Lakers suck.
And I remember thinking as a fan,
this sucks.
We're going to be good and they suck.
It's like if the red sox good and the Yankees suck or vice versa,
it's not fun.
Right.
And all of a sudden Lebron is going to move.
And where does he go to the fucking Lakers?
And next year that's going to be a bunch of free agents
and the Lakers we'll stock up and again,
we're going to go into the finals.
It's going to be fucking Lakers,
Celtics.
You know,
if anybody can get past that juggernaut of,
of,
um,
uh,
golden state.
But like,
I dunno,
I think it's all,
uh,
it's definitely finessed like a,
like a boxing promoter putting together,
like the fact that they let Kevin Duran go to the golden state warriors and the
last two seasons have been an absolute fucking snooze fest.
It's like they,
you knew they were going to win it the second he went there and they did,
you knew they were going to go back to back and they did.
Okay.
What date do it and golden state is,
is like what the fuck and Yankees did.
Okay.
In the early two thousands and the height of them buying championships was when
they got fucking a rod.
Anything Post 1998 cause I love that Yankee team.
I don't want the Yankees,
but I love that team.
[inaudible] 99 2000,
the Clemens,
all of that bullshit,
um,
was all those pile on fucking championships.
And then the red sox were like,
well what the fuck?
You know,
we're in the middle of a 90 year drought,
86 year drought here.
This is,
this is,
this is the game.
We got to play this game.
And this is the thing,
we haven't stopped playing that fucking game.
I mean,
nobody could be as bad as the fucking Yankees.
remember they had fucking geometry and a rod in Jeter and they're fucking
infield.
It was ridiculous.
They had to have the best shortstop in the league,
in their infield.
One agreeing to play third base was fucking nuts.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
whatever.
So anyways,
so the Braun is a Laker and uh,
I guess I'm going to get my wish that they're going to be in the finals,
hopefully against us.
I mean,
that's who I want to play and beat.
Um,
okay.
And I like our coach better and you know,
I know that they're going to go out and get a zillion guys because everybody in
the NBA wants to play in La.
Not Cause,
you know,
partially because they love the Lakers,
but who doesn't want to fuck a famous broad,
right?
Who Does it want?
Fucking 75,
80 degree weather year round.
I've said this forever.
What do you want to,
do you want to go to Boston Racist Boston and deal with the winter and fucking
sixes and sevens or do you want to come to racist La Bang supermodels and uh,
go to the beach whenever the fuck you want?
12 months of the year.
I mean,
we can't compete with it.
I mean that uniform literally looks like sunshine.
Hey,
speaking of that go now is in the middle of Minneapolis.
I went by that fucking robbery.
I looked like an old fucking
like
hockey stadium and I would've thought it was the north star old place had I not
known that it used to.
It's where the mall of America is now.
Um,
yeah,
that wasn't a fucking red flag.
Yeah.
We're getting rid of the hockey team and we're putting the biggest fucking mall
ever.
Okay.
Um,
I,
I still don't understand how that fucking thing stays open.
You know,
how do you fucking,
okay.
Yeah.
You know what the mall of America is like.
It's like having a TV show now and it's just so many of them.
I would tell you the time I was talking to a comedian and I told her how much I
liked her show and she was saying thanks and we were talking for five minutes
before she realized I was talking about another show that she had that just got
canceled and she was talking about a different TV show that I didn't even know.
She had two television shows.
And had no fucking idea.
Uh,
anyways,
so I went by the armory thing there and I saw Jennifer Lopez blade there during
the Superbowl.
I guess they redid it,
but the coolest fucking thing ever about that venue is that's where the
Minneapolis Lakers with George Mike and when their first four NBA championships
and that,
uh,
that Ba championship that the Lakers still calling NBA championship,
which is fucking hilarious.
They somehow one one all right before the NBA existed.
But anyways,
I really wanted to go in there and take a fucking tour of it.
So,
uh,
so there we go.
I know a lot of you guys are expecting me to flip out that fucking Lebron went
to.
I don't give a shit.
I like who a,
I'll.
Thank you.
How are you?
Lovely.
Near thumbs up.
Oh Yeah,
nothing
you feel rundown.
I didn't give it to you today.
That didn't get to get you sick,
did I?
No,
I don't think so.
As full rundown.
All right,
cool.
Okay.
Thanks for taking notes.
Okay,
bye.
Uh,
yeah,
my wife was sick too.
You know,
I was also sick,
but you know,
my wife was also kind of sick,
but I was really sick.
So you know what was going to happen,
right?
She's going to sleep in and I'm going to handle the kid.
That's just how it works.
How,
what,
where you want to keep peace in the house.
That's how it works.
He just fucking get baby the shit out of them,
you know?
And I would love to say that.
I'll be able to remember that for the next argument so I can be like,
Whoa,
what about to fucking time?
I was sick of the new I to flow to what?
Your door for the homework.
I will remember it.
I don't have that ability.
You know,
you fucking with a woman,
they're like fucking Matlock.
You know,
I can fucking start pulling.
I never even watched that show,
you know,
but I imagine he was pulling up fucking cases from the past.
I have no idea.
You know what he did last night?
I was on and I couldn't get the fucking sleep.
I was on the Internet there and,
um,
I was seeing watching all this shit on a Dean Martin and Jerry Lewis,
just how big and how famous they got everything.
And after they broke up,
uh,
Dean Martin in about 1958 got in the restaurant business and he opened up Dino's
lodge,
which was basically just west of La Cienega and sunset just south.
Now,
this giant fucking complex there,
but it's a long gone.
I mean they knocked it down to the 80s,
but he got involved in there.
They put his big head there,
Dino's lounge and he went down there and um,
it was a really hip place to go to at first,
late fifties.
I mean,
Dean's Dean and he would actually go down there,
you know,
get the restaurant going,
star struck patrons.
He signed in our graphs and all that shit.
And uh,
do you know,
like fucking two,
three laters Jerry Lewis opened a competing restaurant down the street.
This is how bad it got.
He opened a competing one and then stole Dean Martin's business partner,
um,
to open that one.
And then he had an even bigger picture of himself on the restaurant and it was
on a pole,
like a hundred feet in the air and it wasn't stationary,
it was revolving.
So I guess dean ended up saying,
Hi man,
fuck this shit.
And he got it Coz he's cool.
He said,
fuck this.
He got out of the restaurant business and then he had to sue them to get his
name taken off in the image and he couldn't get it taken off.
And they,
his face state on that restaurant until like the fucking 80 is like I said,
when they finally fucking took it out.
But um,
okay.
Anyways,
I just can't imagine that it got that bad,
which of course led me to the 1976 reunion that they had on the Jerry Lewis
Telethon with Jerry had no idea dean was coming out.
Frank brought him out.
Uh,
that was cool watching them.
I'll get all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
It's just stupid fucking falling out stuff.
Um,
but I just thought it was funny at the height,
at the fucking height of them hating each other.
They had competing fucking restaurants.
How nuts to comedians.
You know,
I just picture matching like De Niro in casino count in the fucking blueberries
in the muffin.
Okay.
Freaking out doing that crazy Jerry Lewis voice saying how Ddo has more
blueberries and his muffin and this is fucking unacceptable.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
oh,
Billy is a
fucking gonna hang around in the house here and get over this shit actually feel
a thousand times better than I felt yesterday.
Um,
I just need to walk around.
They sent weird thing,
you know,
when he gets sick where you supposed to lay around and relax and you know each,
is it,
why is it each soup?
You know what I mean?
You slurp it,
right?
This one is hybrid things.
It's almost a gas and a liquid.
It's not a solid,
you know,
it is a liquid and it's a solid,
that's what it is.
It's like a super group of food.
Um,
okay.
No,
it isn't bill.
It's like cereal.
If you heated it up.
Yeah.
What do you put that,
you know,
do you know?
I saw when I was on the road,
I actually saw a Pringles potato chips and they had deal flavor and I love
fucking dill pickles and I love Pringles potato chips.
And those two came together and I couldn't get myself to do it because it just,
it was coming across like it was going to be like a super group,
you know?
Like what if we took fucking Robert Plant and fucking stuck them with Keith
Moon?
Remember they would do shit like that and then he's just,
and then it just never sounded good cause the vibe wasn't there.
I'm just so worried that that's what it's going to be.
And on some level like,
um,
you know,
it's going to ruin my enjoyment of original Pringles and,
uh,
and dill pickles.
You want to level of Pringles,
they taste delicious.
And I'm an,
I'm a bit of a neat freak,
although my office is a fucking mess right now.
You know,
I hate fucking dishes in the sink the next morning.
It like depresses me.
I fucking knock 'em out.
You,
uh,
basically an incredible father and husband is what I'm telling you.
That's my version of it.
My,
it's my version of the story.
Eventually we'll have neon here when she's feeling better and then she'll
probably tell you the truth that I'm a fucking asshole over there.
Did Anybody Watch the fucking Austrian a Formula One race?
That is my favorite fucking Formula One race that I've been,
that I've ever watched and I've only watched since Monaco 2016 and I've missed a
few here or there.
Um,
absolutely loved that fucking race.
I'm a huge fan of Max for staff and I feel like he's the next guy came and
Daniel Ricardo,
right in Daniel.
Ricardo's gonna fucking leave red bull.
I don't know where he's going to go.
Ferrari.
I don't know if there's room in the Mercedes seem,
I have no fucking idea,
but it was just like the top two guys.
Uh,
what's his face?
Max Verstappen and Kimmy raking and they're fucking hilarious.
Their press conferences are hilarious thereafter.
They just,
they don't give a shit.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
they just,
they have like that comic's comic vibe about them.
Like I know when,
um,
I was talking about the last time,
uh,
Sebastian Vettel had bagged into a couple people in Max for staff and during
the,
um,
after the press conference,
he goes,
you guys should tell him he should change his style of driving.
You know,
cause they had said that to him and that Tim,
uh,
Max early in the season,
then he goes and then fucking Sebastian should continue to drive exactly the way
he's driving cars.
That I haven't changed anything.
And now you guys aren't shitting on him because of winning by the way.
And then the United States,
the hosteen came in fifth and sixth.
That's like our highest place ever was at fourth and fifth or fifth and sixth.
It might've been fourth to fifth.
I got to look it up here.
I can't remember.
But a Mercedes though.
Oh my God,
they had a fucking brutal day.
Brule date.
It's sucks cause I wanted,
um,
he always want to see like a close race at the end.
Um,
but I got to be,
I'm a little jaded with this sport where I was just,
you know,
after the first term,
which was,
and it was a fucking incredible start to the race.
MMM.
And I remember when,
when Lewis Hamilton,
uh,
got into first place after the first year and I got so over,
he's gonna win.
He's going to win it.
Put the track was so fucking hot.
That tire started,
the blister.
Some bullshit happened.
I don't know what and what's his face.
Uh,
no.
We came in fourth and fifth,
Grogan and magnificent fourth and fifth.
Um,
the hospital,
um,
I don't know what happened.
Somebody was going to fucking slow or something that caused Lewis Hamilton.
They have to slow down.
And then he got passed and then he had to go into the,
the fucking pits.
Wish that you had to do one extra pit stop is what happened.
And that fucked him.
But that guy is such a good driver.
Even in the end,
the other guy's tires were starting to blister up and he was,
she was just right fucking and then all the drama went out when he fucking his
car,
shit,
the bed.
And I believe,
uh,
Valtteri Botox adds some sort of gearbox failure.
But um,
and also what's his face?
Uh,
um,
Daniel Ricardo is his fucking car shit.
The bed too.
He's been having a rough go of it.
But uh,
I just liked it cause it,
it just put different people in the lead that I haven't seen.
I know Max Verstappen has done well over the last few.
Um,
but it was,
it was just fun to watch all of that shit.
Um,
and then watch Louis Hamilton having like the,
the fastest lap of the race trying to catch up like Bill Elliot back in the day
and the stock car races and a then unfortunately his car,
shit the bed.
But is the big thing was he was up 14 points.
Lewis Hamilton over Sebastian Vettel Vettel came in third and I believe you get
15 points and Lewis Hamilton got no points.
So now Vettel is leapfrog to pass him and he's up one point,
um,
because I was hoping he wasn't going to slowly fucking pull away.
I think they race again next week in Great Britain and then they might be on
their break.
There's summer break and then there'll be neck and neck for the rest of the
year.
So far Ferrari can fucking hang in there.
It should be exciting,
right through a Brazil and on into November where they,
what do they always end up?
He said Dubai,
I can't fucking remember.
Um,
so anyways,
very fucking excited about that race.
Uh,
I mean it sucked.
You know,
the Mercedes get knocked out.
This is also Daniel Ricardo,
but it was just fun to see some new blood up there and then,
you know,
watching Louis Hamilton putting on a fucking show as he was dealing with,
with his tires literally falling apart.
Um,
anyways,
when I was,
uh,
when I was in also when I was in Minneapolis and forgot to tell you I was going
to try a different place to get a juicy Lucy.
Last time I went to maths bar and I got this fucking Uber driver.
It's hilarious.
This Indian guy,
and there's a lot of construction going on downtown in Minneapolis and it said
he was five minutes away for 15 minutes.
He finally pulls up and this dude was like the fucking old Indian version of me.
Like he was like snapping on me cause he was mad about construction.
But I understood it because like it took me a minute to figure out like,
why is this guy yelling at me?
I go,
I want to go to a whatever the fuck it was.
The five [inaudible] club was going to try that one next,
right?
And he goes,
I need an address medially yelling at me.
I go,
all right dude,
relax.
No,
you can't just say that.
Never in a place I need an address.
I was like to stop yelling at me.
He goes,
I'm not yelling at you,
aren't you?
Yes.
You argue,
yell at.
And then verse,
he gets to the car,
he's looking at me.
I'm like,
dude,
this guy's fucking not,
you know,
this guy's yelling at me and he goes,
I need an address.
And I'm like,
well,
the name of the place is,
is,
is the five eight club putting your phone,
your fucking cunt.
Right.
So now I went to his energy,
but fortunately I've been really working on it and I brought it back down again
and I was just like,
hey,
all right.
You know,
like I just stand this traffic here,
right?
Let's,
and then he was trying to smile his way to realize that he went to fucking nuts.
So I think I gave the wrong address.
He'd have taken us to mad,
sparse.
So now it's like really tense Barb.
Nick's riding in the front seat and this fucking guys,
it looks like we're with our fucking angry grandfather.
We were all trying to be on our best behavior.
So Barton is,
tries to lighten the mood.
We see this fat chick on a bicycle,
you know,
she was at a dead stop and that she's trying to get it going.
So it's just like,
you know,
it's precarious when you start off a bike.
If you're not pedaling fast enough,
especially when you're carrying that kind of weight.
And Bar Party was a Jesus Christ looking around.
He goes,
they don't have assets like that.
Nydia dude,
he's like maybe on an elephant.
Right.
And the guy started laughing.
I was,
it's like,
yeah,
there'll be a fucking sacred cow over there.
And we just fucking broke the ice.
We broke the ice by making fun of a fat chick and bringing up stereotypical shit
from that guy's culture.
That's how we did it.
And then he pulled up,
he ended up pulling up to maths bar instead of the five,
eight club.
And I was like,
oh,
this isn't where I wanted to go.
And he kind of looked at me.
I was just like to forget it.
It's all right.
It's fine.
I,
I don't wanna get yelled at again.
I was living like a battered wife at that point.
Like,
okay,
Bye Dad.
I love you.
Just fucking drove off.
Um,
all right,
let me read,
let me read a little bit of a,
by the way,
it was delicious.
And they,
they have,
uh,
they get middle,
a hot Miller high life in a bottle there.
You know what the dangerous thing about a Miller high life is?
There's just something about the bottle.
It feels like it's eight ounces.
It just doesn't feel like it's 12 ounces of beer and they just,
they just go down so easy,
you know?
And I had a show that night,
so,
uh,
you know,
ended up having a,
I think we had like two and the waitress was cool,
you know,
she was asking us about the show.
We ended up hooking her up and then she gave us some fucking hats and shit,
man,
it was really just,
it was fucking Minneapolis is fucking awesome.
The people up there are fucking awesome.
And then I go to Detroit,
you know,
the fucking great.
And I asked,
it was actually like,
as I just literally landed,
went to the hotel and then went out and did the show.
So I was doing my typical Detroit material,
but how white people,
you know,
drive a hundred miles an hour into,
uh,
the tiger's game and after the,
you know,
and then drive back out cause it's so fucked up in the downtown area.
And I knew it was making a comeback.
Every time I go there it's a little bit nicer.
But two,
it's like those jokes are over now.
I walked out after my show at about 10 30 at night and I saw a white guy,
a white kid on a bicycle with a backpack riding down the street,
not even nervous.
And I was just like,
like,
it's,
it's in a real estate sense,
it's too late to buy there.
You're already going to be paying like fucking top shelf prices if the
neighborhood got to the point where a white guy will ride down the street late
at night,
you know,
with a backpack on,
he wasn't like a fucking,
you know,
he wasn't like eight mile m and m white guy.
He was a white guy like me,
you know,
a suburban,
a suburban night,
a non dancing suburban white kid.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
they had like a John Varvatos downtown.
It was fucking ridiculous.
I remember years ago,
I was telling Versie going through it,
I'm going to buy some property here.
This place is gonna fucking blow up because you're out of your mind.
I was just like,
dude,
it's a no,
but
it's here.
It's just what I saw this happen in Pittsburgh.
I saw this happen in Cleveland.
I just didn't have fucking money at the time was I was fucking putting in in
this God damn,
you know,
fucking money pit of a house that I bought a nice house.
Now it's a nice house now,
but I,
this is literally body off restoration.
I had to do this fucking house,
sorry.
Anyways,
uh,
and I remember seeing on the Anthony Bourdain show,
parts unknown,
rest his soul.
I saw a guy,
he bought a skyscraper there for 5 million bucks and I was thinking through
this,
any way you could scrape together 5 million bucks and then renovate it,
which I don't know what that would cost another 50,
45.
And if you could just sit on that,
I mean,
there's still a way that it's a skyscraper.
Well that city makes a comeback,
that thing,
you know,
say his 60 billion it,
it's going to be worth a quarter of $1 billion.
And you know,
fucking did all that shit.
The uh,
the owner of the Cleveland Cavaliers,
he went down there,
he bought a bunch of fucking buildings,
redid them,
had made the office a space cheap and he filled them up with these internet
companies and um,
made me feel good.
Then I was going to make the same moves at a billionaire fucking owner of a
basketball team was going to make,
I just sit down the fucking money.
Um,
anyways,
but I'm very,
very happy for that city as I was for Cleveland as I am for Pittsburgh and all
that shit.
Cause has such great cities,
Buffalo,
Baltimore,
all of those cities going right through the Dayton.
I love all of those fucking cities and they,
and all they need is just people to fucking invest in them.
You know what I mean?
I'll tell you when we're done free in the Iraqis.
We shot to come back here and try to help out some of these fucking cities.
Get them going again.
Start Building Shit.
You know,
if I was running shit,
I'd have these fucking hipsters,
right?
I would just have them like,
what are you into right now?
What are you going to bring back from the past and do it in some artisan fucking
way and you know,
just,
you know,
give him a break on factories and shit.
You just start making stuff here again.
You know,
say what you want about hipsters.
They like a lot of cool stuff.
They just insufferable to talk to.
Um,
all right,
the black box.
Oh,
sorry.
The Black Tux.
I don't know if that was from watching too much porn or it having a pilot's
license.
The Black Tux,
a wedding season is upon us.
Uh,
you're going to be doing it big and going out to all your buddies weddings.
When you bringing a date,
you want to look fresh.
Yeah.
You want to hook up.
You don't to bring a,
you want to go there like fucking Jim Carrey,
dumb and dumber,
but have a cool Tuxedo.
But it has to be convenient.
That's where the black,
the black Tux comes in.
The black tops has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles.
And your rent them online.
All right.
I just hit pause and I blew my nose while it wasn't recording.
See,
I learned from my mistakes.
The black Tux offers the kind of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally be
wildly expensive to buy and you might only wear it.
What's like the Emerald Shawl?
Tuxedo?
It's funky.
It's cool.
But how many times you get aware an Emerald Green Tuxedo with the Black Tux?
You can.
Okay.
You can do you and blow it out for your big event.
One.
One time event.
Yeah.
You gotta you gotta go with something a little bit flashy.
Okay.
It don't bring a fucking date automatically before you an open your mouth,
you're going to seem interesting.
Forget about when the ladies start drinking.
Next thing you know,
you're out there doing the mock arena,
right?
And you're like,
why would you ever get married?
And that's called beating your 20s alright,
so try out a new look.
Do something different.
It takes your style to the next level.
With the Black Tux,
free home,
try on,
you can see the fit and feel the quality of your suits month,
months before the event.
It's a hard word to say,
plural months.
Let me do that for fucking months,
I think I say months.
M U s once.
Yeah,
and you went to see after ordering your suit after ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a replacement right away.
And remember how simple returns are where it turned heads and then send it back
three days after your event.
Shipping is free.
Both ways.
Standout at your event for the right reason with the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase,
visit the Black tux.com/bird that's the black tux.com/burr for $20 off your
purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos though.
All right,
here we go.
Lastly,
but certainly not leastly simply safe.
Here's what I love about simply save these guys.
Obsess over details.
It's why the alarm system is so good.
Here's an example.
A typical glass break sensors sometimes gets fooled.
A false positive sounds like dropping plates,
a baby crying.
Oh,
then it freaks out.
It says the British are coming or the sky's falling.
Simply safe,
didn't want it settled for a typical,
didn't want to set up for typical because really good home security should be
really accurate.
So they actually considered a glass break.
Test Facility.
Okay,
well they have a bunch of toddlers in there throwing glasses.
They ran over 10,000 live glass break simulations,
refining their technology.
The detection technology,
until it was so accurate,
it continues to,
can distinguish a broken plate from a broken window.
Okay,
Jesus Christ.
Can you believe somebody knows to like make up fucking a little piece of
electronics?
Understand that
everything,
how not relevant you're going to be in 10 years.
This is the level of detail.
Simply safe puts into everything they do.
It's sets them apart from other security companies.
Simply safe system is designed so you will never notice it.
Never have to think about it.
It's that easy and intuitive.
There's no contract.
They work hard to earn your business.
24,
seven monitoring with police and fire dispatch.
It's just $15 a month.
It's the best around the quad protection you can find.
Protect your home today.
Visit simply safe bird.com now,
that's simply safer.com simply safe bird.com um,
you ever think why the people at the top are not concerned about the environment
generally speaking and how they're content to just fucking use up all the oil.
Kill as many people as they need to kill to get the fucking oil,
you know,
pollute the air as much as they can.
Throw the fucking rivers.
Why they don't give a shit?
You know,
how was just sticking?
I think it's because we're all good.
You know,
all US regular people are going to get replaced by robots.
You know what I mean?
The love robot Comedians,
you know,
robot fucking whores,
whatever the hell you want it,
you know,
I don't know.
Kind of ran out of jobs there,
but you know what I mean.
And then there's still going to,
they're still going to live and they're going to be that upper 1% and they're
going to have like,
just like essentially,
uh,
an entire population that never complains is totally into what the fuck they're
doing.
I think they'll keep,
uh,
a group of people.
She would beings as slaves and there's job will be to fuck and make more people
so that these older fucking rich one percenters can harvest their organs and
live forever.
That's what I think.
Those are the kinds of things that I think when I'm alone,
um,
have you got to figure the first time you kill somebody for the,
your organs,
you could just going to do that forever.
Cause it's like,
well I don't if there's a higher power,
I don't think I want to meet him or her with,
with that on the resume,
you know,
God just sit across to you.
Well you were busy
sitting there,
shifted in that fucking chair.
You just fucking know exactly what the fuck he's do you know exactly what he's
talking about.
Like that one's going to pop out and get you got everybody's got probably that
one thing except for truly good people,
which I'm not,
you know,
that can fire,
when I die,
if there was an afterlife,
I feel like God's to f like fucks with you.
Like you sit across the room and he just looks down at your,
your resume,
right.
Probably has like the half glasses,
you know,
sitting on the end of his fucking all mighty knows eyebrows up and shit and they
just kind of looks across the ace.
Probably like a,
you want me to,
you want,
you want to tell me about this,
you know?
And then you're sitting there going,
fuck,
what's he talking about?
Is this a trick?
Uh,
Oh shit.
He can hear what I'm thinking.
Don't think about all the shit you did,
Bill.
He's got to know.
It's gonna be such a mind.
Fuck.
Um,
anyways,
that's a weird fucking topic of dying,
uh,
with a fuck around my,
what the Hell is all my shit?
Oh,
there it is.
It's trying to find them like my fucking shit.
I wanted to talk about,
okay.
Detroit's fucking gorgeous white dude on a bicycle.
Too late to invest.
She,
that's what I do.
I just wanted a couple of words.
Oh yeah.
That's what I wanted to talk about.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm so psyched to be back out here in Los Angeles.
You know,
when I was in Detroit,
um,
it's weird when I was in Minneapolis,
I already what they were known for,
which is the juicy Lucy,
which is a fucking incredible,
like the one it Matt's bar.
They got this nice char on it.
Then they got the cheese of course in the middle and it's molten hot,
so you gotta be careful,
nibble,
nibble around the outside.
And um,
so it was,
it was delicious.
And,
um,
there was ice cold.
It was fucking great.
It made me wish I didn't have a show that night.
I was like,
I think I want another one of these and I want to sit here and just fucking
watch a game,
you know?
And,
um,
but then I went to Detroit
and,
um,
you know,
I ordered Tacos,
stupid fucking roof.
I mean they were good but they weren't,
but you know,
they're not la to la knows is known for Tacos.
San Francisco is known for Burritos
and I'm known for being pasty.
Oh,
let's talk World Cup.
Shall We?
Let's see what's going on in the FIFA World Cup.
I watched a couple of games.
Um,
I can't even tell you who the fuck I saw.
I did see the highlights.
So when I wanted to watch was Brazil in Mexico,
you know what I mean?
I mean that was just a fucking soccer supernova as far as I was concerned about
Russia beaten spade.
Okay.
That,
that,
that was like the fucking lake placid moment,
you know.
And I was sitting immediately go like,
oh this is going to be weird.
It's Russia keeps moving along,
you know,
you watch America's going to be a bunch of babies about it,
cause everybody's already saying that they kind of fucked with our election or
whatever.
And,
uh,
you know,
of course he let you now the World Cup.
They don't like we give a shit,
uh,
book game that I watch.
I watched the Dutch people play.
Uh,
uh,
fuck,
I can't remember.
But the other people want some of the best goaltending I've seen in soccer ever.
The fucking game starts,
first of all,
uh,
the Dutch guys,
right?
I was at Denmark,
Denmark,
right?
They fucking a Denmark Dutch people.
Is that the Netherlands?
I Dunno,
I'm an American.
They don't talk about the rest of the world.
Okay.
They talk about the fucking white people that started this country.
That's what gets driven into your fucking skull.
MMM.
So the uh,
Denmark scores a goal like 40 seconds in or a minute in or something like that.
And then like 45 seconds later,
the other guys score,
the guys who won,
okay.
Can't fucking remember Croatia,
Slovakia,
Slovenia,
Romania.
Um,
I don't know who the fuck it was.
They fucking score.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this is finally my dream game.
Minute and a half.
And there's already been two goals.
This is some shit American can appreciate.
And then there wasn't another goal for like another fucking hour and a half.
But,
uh,
I do have to say the goaltending was fucking incredible.
All right.
And that guy with his fucking golden fucking
locks there go come head for fucking
Denmark was incredible.
And then the other guy was just a fucking lunatic.
One of those guys,
you could tell he can't shut it off after the game and they would just guessing,
right?
Uh,
they dive and then the guy would shoot to the Middle East,
fucking get his foot out while he was dive in the other way.
And whenever you miss a penalty fucking kick,
like is,
is the shooter,
whatever the fuck you call them,
right?
They,
you know that they're fucking,
they're just thinking like,
Oh God,
I'm going to get fucking,
I'm never going to hear the end of this when I go back to my country,
I'm never going to hear the fucking end of this,
you know,
unless somebody steps up and saves my fucking ass.
So I did see that game.
I did see the Brazil game where that Rinaldo Guy,
oh my God.
I thought for half a second he was literally on fire,
you know,
like when will Ferrell was running around and Ricky Bobby with the invisible
flames,
he was tearing off all his clothes.
I thought that that's what was what was happening.
Um,
I mean,
I know the guys,
it definitely should have been a penalty.
It was a piece of shit move.
The guy stepped on him.
He raped his fucking cleat right across his ankle.
I imagine it's smarted,
but she's as Christ that was like silent film acting.
MMM.
Penny wins against Brazil.
One,
two to nothing.
And uh,
we're getting down to it.
So I imagine France or England was playing today,
right now Francis going to play,
they were already in like a,
they're already,
what do I look it up?
FIFA World Cup standings.
And then you've got to fight through all these CBS sports cons that don't
fucking have it.
I want the grid and what the bracket,
give me the bracket.
World Cup bracket,
CBS sports.
You get to fuck me against CBS sports.
Come on
slowly opening
this fucking website sucks.
It keeps saying brackets.
It doesn't have the bracket.
Whereas eyebrow kit,
yeah,
there's nothing I can,
I can click on schedule.
The standards are,
and who the fuck's playing today?
World Cup schedule.
I'm clicking.
Okay.
Ah,
you fucking ass.
Or Russia?
2018 schedule.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I found the bracket.
All right.
Oh,
I watched the Arra.
Gwaii always sells Uruguay.
Earl grey beat Portugal.
I watched that game.
Shut up.
I watched uh,
Croatia be dead.
My,
okay.
MMM.
I guess Sweden beat Switzerland.
The lovable,
I don't know why they breed VH one for their countries.
Sui.
There's no you in Switzerland.
Why would it be WWE?
Is that too close to Sweden?
Yes.
MMM.
Brazil is clean.
Belgium.
All right.
So the last person who has to get in is,
is England,
is playing Columbia.
Yeah.
When the fuck is that game,
I got to take that one.
Then they get into the quarter finals,
then there's the semis,
and then there's a final game.
Fucking goes by so fast.
So there's one,
two,
there's three,
basically three more rounds.
MMM.
And I'm going to watch it for once.
I don't think I've watched the final since that guy from Italy missed that
penalty shot.
Okay.
You know,
but I,
I remember when I was a kid,
way back in the 80s,
Diego Maradona,
they hand to God and all of that Shit.
But uh,
other than that,
I remember also it was in the,
it wasn't it in the u s I'm like 94 and like 30 Americans showed up,
but it's still sold out because everybody around the world was like so excited.
Like,
oh my God,
it's going to be so easy to get tickets.
Let's go.
MMM.
All right,
let's read some,
uh,
some of the fucking questions here for the week.
Was it really,
really neat to swear right there?
All right.
Um,
where are we?
Sweden.
Oh,
speaking of that,
please come to sweet.
And last time you were here,
I was a little kid and it didn't know about you,
but I really liked your podcasts and your standup is amazing,
isn't it?
Like how young that person is.
I haven't been there in about five years,
you know?
So what do you mean,
like 15 you'd probably still already like five,
11,
all super tall kids of uh,
I'm putting together an eastern European tour by the way.
Um,
hopefully for the beginning part of next year.
I'm teasing that,
that that's what's going to be happening.
And if we go into a bunch of countries that I've never been to before and uh,
but I know I to get back to Sweden.
I haven't been there and way too way too long.
So I will definitely get back there.
All right.
Uh,
thank you for the compliments of my podcasts and my stand up.
A,
can a comic cover a comedic bit like a musician?
Uh,
no they can't.
They can't.
Let's he tells everybody,
remember that Cosby bid?
You remember that prior bit?
Dear bill one rant away from an aneurysm birth.
I hit how true that is.
Ken.
I want to be Standup Co.
Oh,
want to be staying?
You're not an actual standup comedian.
Cover a comedic bit like a wannabe musician would cover his son.
I'm not talking about a paid gig.
Just an open mic.
Nah,
don't do that.
Cause you're already,
you're,
even though you're not a pro,
cause you're not getting paid.
You are,
yeah,
you don't do that.
This is,
there's no coffee house of standup comedy sets your professional like yourself
and are putting on a special,
it should be total original content.
Uh,
the thing is not all of us are as funny as you,
but we still want to make the world laugh and get a taste of the spotlight and
maybe some groupie pussy to,
and if you think you're going to go up on an open mic,
I don't give a fuck if you kill with original material.
When you get off stage,
you still have to have game.
That's the thing about being a comedian as a fucking musician.
You go up there and you start singing a song,
it's fucking over.
I mean you,
you,
you can do that at a fucking coffee house singing other people's fucking songs
and it's just going to be rain in fucking vagina.
Uh,
comedians,
we can go up there for an hour,
hour and a half with our own material and you still have to work for it.
You know,
they want you to still be funny when you get off stage.
Keep being funny keeping.
They know what the other guy to fucking sing.
He can sit there brooding,
you know,
smoking a cigarette.
Um,
anyways.
Now your initial response will probably be something along the lines.
No,
go write your own material.
You lazy piece of Shit.
Uh,
you call me illiterate.
At least I can write my own jokes.
Oh,
you trying out material right now?
I did my time in the nightclubs bombing on stage and as a young,
skinny redhead.
And you don't think I just wanted to go out there,
blah,
blah.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You leave these Lazy Co.
Uh,
the thing is I don't strive to be a professional comedian as,
as engineering pays a lot better.
And writing my own jokes seems like too much work too.
I really don't give a shit about you right now.
You know what I mean?
Hey Man,
like I,
you know,
I mean,
I just want to go fucking uh,
play once one down of professional football without getting hit.
Yeah,
go fuck yourself.
Uh,
I just want to go on stage and give the illusion that I'm funny.
So maybe a girl will think I actually have a personality.
You want to fuck me?
Oh,
now we're getting to it.
Now we're getting to it.
All right.
So you're an engineer.
You probably introverted,
you're super smart,
but you don't have anything going on with the ladies.
So right now you think in leg,
so you'll,
oh,
that's funny.
And then you think that funny guys,
comedians get a ton of ass.
Uh,
I'm not saying there are guys out there that do,
but they work.
It's fucking,
or unless you know,
you fucking ridiculously good looking,
but like it's fucking work.
Um,
if it is,
if you're extending a comedian,
you kind of have like that slumber vibe,
slumber party,
vibe,
energy,
like all my God,
you guys,
it's weird.
It's like a feminine,
you know,
fuel must,
it's a weird thing about women.
If you give off an a feminine energy,
you're actually going to get more fucking ass than a fucking,
uh,
a guy
or I guess a guy vibe.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
look at David Bowie,
the guy was walking around wearing dresses that was just women with prince was
wearing high heel shoes,
his whole fucking they eat,
they,
it was like a a lick the locust,
except it was all vaginas flying at those guys.
So maybe that's what you need to do rather than,
uh,
rather than steel from comedians.
I would steal from Prince and David Bowie and I would think that you guys are
all down there.
Everybody's wearing like the fucking white lab coat.
If you added a little bit of Flair of feminine flare to your scientific is
scientist coat,
who knows,
go to work,
design a bridge while wearing some fucking prince high yields,
fucking boots,
uh,
telling you you're,
you're automatically,
you're going to be fucking interesting.
All right,
let me keep reading here.
Uh,
I just want to go save blah,
blah,
blah.
He goes,
I look at it like it's a scientific report.
It's not plagiarism as long as you cite where you got the information from.
So if at the beginning of the set I said something like most essays I wrote in
college,
this set is completely plagiarized.
That's a funny joke,
sir.
Consisting of ideas from people much smarter than me.
And the only original thing I have to say is this opening line in some asshole
somewhere else has probably already said this too.
Or at the end of the set I say,
thanks for listening.
If you want to see those jokes,
they're actually supposed to be performed.
How those shows are actually supposed to be foam.
Go check up Pilbara dude.
You're,
you're,
you're cutting yourself short.
You're actually a funny guy.
You're just lazy.
Um,
you could actually use that opener and then go into one of the oldest jokes of
all time,
you know,
one of those fucking Warren,
a fireman's where red suspenders and be like,
I'm just fucking with you.
And then to just talk about being a fucking engineer and I got no game with
women.
You only have to be up there for five minutes.
All right to that,
I actually think you want to fucking do this.
And I also think you funny from that first line,
all right?
So there's,
there's a year two options.
All right?
If,
if you sincerely from an unoriginal fan from the great white north,
you're funny,
you're self deprecating,
you got enough here that it,
it's not crazy to me that,
that you would go up and do an open mic.
But uh,
you know,
it's the laziness factor that you just want to go up there and do other people's
shit.
But I understand.
I remember the first time I sat down to write like,
okay,
I'm going to write jokes.
It's the weirdest feeling ever.
It's like,
how do you do this?
Like what do I even fucking,
what am I going to talk about?
How do I connect one idea to another?
You're not supposed to know.
All right?
So just open with that line.
Talk about your life.
You know,
who gives a fuck if you bail after three minutes?
That's what I did.
I even get through the five minutes and look at me.
Tell a Dick Jokes all across the lead.
All right?
But,
um,
you're not going to get respect from other comics.
Other open Miker is going up.
They're doing other people's fucking material,
and you will immediately be branded a thief.
Watch out for this guy,
and it'll be a bunch of open makers who are severely insecure and they're going
to need a target to fucking focus.
They're awful childhoods on,
and that's going to be you.
So I would open with that joke.
I would close with what the fuck he said.
I wouldn't do other people's material.
I talk about my life and when you're at work,
you know,
whatever,
put a bow on Asub shit.
Trying to be interesting and a bag.
One of the egg chick she fucking work with.
You know,
you guys can't go see star wars or something.
I Dunno.
Good luck to you.
All right everybody,
I'll check in on you on our Thursday.
I'll check it out.
Uh,
I have a great couple of days.
You fucking suck.
Let's go.
Fuck yourself.